من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي
سجل لواء ما الذي نفهمه من توسيع القوات
التركيه قصفها لشمال السوري خاصه استهداف
مواقع في منطقه الحسكه
يعني هذا هو اليوم الثالث عشر الرابع عشر
وبالتالي الخطاب التركي السياسي في صعود
وهبوط
تقاسم ادوار بين الرئيس ووزير الدفاع
ووزير الخارجيه خلال ال- ال-47 ساعه
الماضيه كنا نتوقع نوع من انخفاض مستوى
التصريحات التركيه في هذا اليوم فاجانا
الرئيس التركي باعاده باسراره على انشاء
الممر الامن
عمليه السيف المخلب هي في تصعيد مستمر
كورقه ضغط رئيسيه لان تركيا ارسلت من خلال
الامريكيين والروس خمسه مطالب رئيسيه
احدها الممر الامن وعلى رقم اثنين انشاء
نقاط مراقبه مستقر لاو مشتركه نصب كاميرات
مراقبه تسليم ما بين سبعه الى عشره من
قاده اا حزب العمال الكردستاني يتواجد على
الجغرافيا السوريه وهناك طلب اضافي ان بعض
منتجات شرق الفرات يجب ان يصل جزء منها
الى غرب الفرات هذه المطالب تم نقلها رفضت
من مظلوم عبدي هدد بايقاف التعاون
ومتابعه داعش اذا ما هو البديل البديل في
حال عدم وجود موافقه ضوء اخضر شيعه امريكي
ايراني
وعدم وجود رفض بالمطلق اذا هناك نقطه
بينيه ما بين الضوء الاخضر والرفض المطلق
وهي الموافقه على عمليه محدوده هذا يعني
هاغده من التصحيح يتوافق هذا التحليل مع
ما قالته واشنطن قالت بان وقف العمليات
المشتركه بينها وبين الاخرين سيكون له
انعكاس على مواجهه تنظيم الدوله هكذا قالت
واشنطن ما رايك
يعني تنظيم الدوله هو الشماعه التي دمرت
المنطقه من خلالها لا نود ان ندخل كيف
صنعت ومن اوجدها وكيف تمددت وكيف قضي
عليها ولكنها كانت شماعه لتحقيق اهداف
الان حجم التواجد الامريكي 900 جندي في
تقارير اخرى 2000 جندي موزع على ما بين 20
الى 27 نقطه تجمع وقاعده بدءا من التنف
وانتهاء بالمالكيه ومرورا بعين العرب
وبالتالي هذا الوقف لم يترجم على الارض
على التقرير عرضها اربعه اليات احداها
عائده الى
القوات همم قوات الاسد اذا ادعني اقول كل
طرف يهدد بورقه قوه مملوكه بيده من اجل
تحقيق بعض الشروط ولكن الخمسه
التصاعد في لهجه الكلاميه وايضا ميدانيا
وكان العمليه قد بدات فعلا على الارض
العمليه التركيه
لا احنا الان الحديث
المخلب عمليه جويه قصف مدعي بينما العمليه
البريه هي همم
مثل العمليه نبع السلام غصن الزيتون همم
درع ال- اا درع ادلب الى الى غير ذلك
العمليه البريه في الم- بالمنظور العسكري
تستطيع ان تبدا خلال دقائق من حديثي فقط
الى عين العرب
وكانه يؤشر
ببراوه العمليه العسكريه انها قد بدات
فعلا
يا سيدي الان نتحدث عن حمل جويه طائرات
درون
يتم وطائرات اف 16 تدعم بالقصف المدفعي
والصاروخي وطائرات درون انا اتحدث عن
عمليه بريه ان يتحرك الجنزير الدبابي على
الارض السوريه هنا فرق واضح رئيسي عمليه
دخول القوات لا تزال لا يزال الموقف
الروسي الامريكي الايراني ما همم يقع في
نقطه بين الضوء الاخضر وما بين الرفض
التام واذا استمر الرفض الامريكي التام قد
يتم تاجيل هذه العمليه كما تم تاجيل
العمليه التي تم الحديث عنها في شهر
حزيران الماضي اللواء فايز الدويري
القبيله العسكريه الاستراتيجي متحدثا من
عمان السيد لواء شكرا لك